new this morning the Center for auto
safety is demanding Ford and the
government take action on complaints
about Ford Explorers leaking carbon
monoxide the National Highway Traffic
Safety Administration or Nitsa has
investigated the problem for two years
the number of complaints has grown into
the thousands at least 41 alleged
injuries have been reported but nitsa
has yet to publicly offer any answers
Kris Van Cleave is leading a continuing
CBS News investigation of this problem
Chris good morning
good morning the Center for auto safety
is renewing its call for an immediate
recall of the Ford Explorer safety
advocates are expressing frustration
over the two-year anniversary of the
nitsa investigation and the limited
information that's come out of it
following our reports and the decision
by a number of police departments to
start parking explorers Ford did begin
offering a free repair not a recall
customers have to ask for it the
automaker claims it does effectively
resolve the problem but and this is
important we've found nearly 60
complaints to the regulator from drivers
who say they had that fix and are still
experiencing signs of exhaust or carbon
monoxide seeping into the cabin of their
Ford Explorer we've also found
complaints about the issue starting to
show up in the 2018 Explorer as well
nitsa expanded its investigation last
year following our reports and now
includes more than 1.3 million SUVs from
model years 2011 to 2017 but not the
2018 Ford says the Explorers are safe
and adds complaints are down since they
began offering the free repair still we
found nearly 200 complaints to Nitsa
during that time as for nitsa it says
its investigation is ongoing and
requires testing multiple civilian and
law enforcement vehicles as well as
testing and monitoring Ford's repairs
will stay on it Nora all right that's
important information Chris thank you so
much